You don't see... but you will.
[CACKLES]
[MUFFLED SCREAM]
♪♪
The reason I said no to you
when you first asked me out...
Do you want to go to d-dinner
with me?
Mm-mm.
...and the six times after
that...
-Hey!
-No.
No. No.
...is because I'm moving to
Brazil.
♪♪
-When I got there...
-Mm.
...there was a lake there, a
lagoon.
They told me not to go, but...
I didn't listen.
She told me I had three wishes.
[INTENSE RHYTHMIC BREATHING]
[EMMA]: When it falls off my
wrist,
those three wishes will come true.
[CACKLES]
-Do not cut it.
-[CHUCKLES]
[LAUGHS]
Emma, with me... all three of
your wishes will come true.
♪♪
[KNOCKING AT DOOR]
[MAN]: Would you even know...
[KNOCKING CONTINUES]
[MAN]: ...if you crossed
into a fairy tale?
[KNOCKING CONTINUES]
[WOMAN]: A storm is coming.
[MAN]: There are portals in this
world
that we may never know we've
trespassed through.
♪♪
[CLOCK TICKING]
I need to know where my wife is.
People... don't just disappear!
Witches?
♪♪
You don't see... but you will.